[Music]
hi
i'm galila and until recently
i did not know how to fire up a stove or
operate an oven and the reason for that
is a story
that goes back a couple of generations
it started in the highlands of ethiopia
in a small village called
debra brahan my grandmother lived there
ever since she could remember her entire
life revolved around
her husband and her eight children
my grandmother wanted it to be different
for her daughter
so she went against the prevailing norms
at the time
and she sent her first daughter to
school
my mother became the first woman
in the entire history of my family to be
educated
but although she went to school she did
not have enough time to study
because as a woman she still had
obligations in the kitchen
my mother wanted it to be different for
her daughter me
she believed in education in the same
way that she believed in the ten
commandments
and so she refused point blank to let me
enter the kitchen
instead pushed me to aspire to a life
filled with intellectual and creative
pursuits
this is the reason why i'm here today
also the reason why until recently
i could only make toast in the kitchen
for some time i've been asking myself
this question
why did it take generations for us to
re-examine social norms and change them
why did it take over 50 years could it
be done
quicker within the span of our own lives
i'd like to tell you my story and the
progress i've made thus far and trying
to answer this question
so when i think about my story and how i
learned the values in my community
i think of lego pieces
as a kid i learned the norms and values
of my community
through osmosis piece by piece from
dinner table conversations folklores and
bedtime stories from sunday church
sermons
and school
like most kids i would ask why about
things that didn't make sense to me
or questions about culture
religion why men and women were treated
differently
and the story about the gender dynamics
in my family
was the core foundational piece of my
lego block of values
as you can imagine the answer i got
usually was
i don't know kid it's always been done
this way which is cute for me
to close a chapter on that discussion
and
move on
but i still had questions
in my mind and i would mark them as red
flags that
were unresolved and as i grew older the
number of red flags increased the number
until i had a long list of red flags
at this point it became clear to me that
if i picked up a lego piece
to question and examine it the entire
structure
might completely unravel this was major
cognitive dissonance for me
so here i was apparently i was supposed
to ask engage
question science and math problems in
school but when it came to social things
the things that mattered my values why i
am who i
am why we do things we do
there is no room for critical thinking
so
my kid rain deduced that there must be
two types of ideas in this world
the ideas that you can question
relegated to the scientific realm and
mathematics
and ideas you just accept and faith
but i knew that this way of thinking was
a shortcoming for me
because i noticed i would get emotional
and defensive if anyone tried to
question my lego of values
i could not explain why i believe the
things i did and i could not hold my own
in any debate
then i entered an entirely
new chapter in my life when i moved from
adi sabawa to new york for college
in the dorms in manhattan with an ocean
between me
and my hometown i could take a step back
and take the perspective of an outsider
looking in
you know how monks go off to far-off
caves to
read books and reflect on things this
was my version of that
i poured through ancient texts like
siddhartha
and plato's republic and foundational
texts like the bible
quran i and
the federalist papers written by the
founding fathers of america
i came to a realization that these books
were
essentially giving us the organizing
principle for building our lego of
values
my most meaningful
intellectual breakthrough happened when
i realized
that these books were written by people
who lived hundreds of years ago but
still people
who are no different than me or you
if they can create norms for their time
why shouldn't anybody
should we just take what they've given
us
without questioning this then made me
realize that
i needed to take ownership of my own
value system i needed to
think through what matters to me
so
i started examining my lego values piece
by piece
turning them around rearranging dusting
them off
and some of them some that i
didn't need would chuck them away in the
old and archaic category
effectively murray condoing my values
in this process i came to realize that
the underlying theme
among all of our red flags was this
it was structured this way because you
are x you should not do y
because you are a woman young
black ethiopian christian you should not
do
and the list goes on
my discovery was that to remove red
flags
all that was required was to ask why and
in that process
the fundamental problem in the societal
norm
becomes revealed and that is what the
red flag is covering in the first place
for example in my case
one of my red flags was this because you
are a woman
you should not travel or live on your
own
so after going through the process and
asking why
several times i realized that this came
from a place
of care and protection but
putting artificial constraints
on my movement or my degree of freedom
was not going to solve the root problem
and the problem was that men and women
were treated differently
throughout history and that has resulted
in all sorts of consequences
and so by putting constraints on myself
i wasn't going to solve this problem
so effectively the red flag needed to go
as a first step i moved into my own dorm
and started living on my own
and then i moved into the city got an
apartment by myself
as for traveling i booked a bus ticket
and i did a solo trip solo weekend trip
by myself
and then after a few months i booked
plane tickets
and traveled on my own 25 different
cities around the world
as an aside just like to say to my
parents there's a good reason why i
didn't tell you this
um please forgive me and i will explain
okay going back to my red flags so
in this process i went through resolved
a bunch of red flags
and also learned that red flags
if left unresolved become what our
professors here at stanford call
limiting beliefs or gremlins of the past
that unconsciously hold us back
after many years of critical analysis i
understand why
it's difficult for many of us to go
through this process
and to constantly examine our values
it's challenging it's not pleasant at
all i had nuts in my stomach
every time i tried to go through this
process but
after going through this process is that
i can trace back
where all my values come from and
i have full conviction on
everything that i stand for which is
incredibly empowering
and if we don't go through this process
of
constantly re-examining our values it'll
take us
a long time a whole generation
for us to find inconsistencies in our
communal values
and to find red flags
so my ask is this if any of this
resonated with you
i encourage you to set time
on your calendar once every month
at the end of each month to dust off
your lego values and find red flags
for all the norms in our community
that don't spark joy let's take a moment
to acknowledge them as part of our
history
and say goodbye
and if you know of a kid in your life
brother sister siblings child
nephews encourage them to ask why
so that they so that they are actively
involved
in understanding the norms and values in
the community
let them ask as they build so
they don't have a lego castle that they
need to break down when they're much
older
like me encourage them to ask why
and to be actively involved in
understanding these norms and values
so that they can build from the ground
up and they can build their foundations
as they're at a very young age
i will leave you with this poem
when i was starting off on this journey
a dear friend gave me a poem
that has inspired me to continue on this
path
and it goes like this
there's a sun within every person one of
these days at dawn
you will rise within because you
are a child of the sun
unlike the moon that gets its energy
from other sources
the sun radiates from within and creates
its own energy
like the sun you create your own energy
your own story because the outside world
has no business defining it for you
[Music]